this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad Savages
you it's Monday the 27th of February
this episode of The Joint is brought to
you by freeze pipe my favorites listen
stop burning your lungs when you smoke
get freeze Piper and ice cold hit every
time the pipe comes off the pipe comes
with a detachable chamber you pop that
into your freezer an hour before you
want to jump up and down and get ready
for a high that is cool and refreshing
me I love the freeze pipe I use the bung
and the bubble that's how I roll it's
non-toxic it freezes faster than water
and it stays Frozen for longer freeze
pipe cools down the Smoke by hundreds of
degrees for a more enjoyable inhale
whether you hit that pipe bubbler a bong
or dab they got it all for you so do me
a favor go to the freezepipe.com
pressing code Diaz Diaz to save 10 off
your first order get a bond pipe or
bubble today and I stand behind all
three of them and they're also working
on their own Uncle Joey bong so get
ready for that that's thefreeze pipe.com
pressing code Diaz Diaz to save 10 if
you could smoke out of it freeze pipe
makes it the joint is also brought to
you by all Jesus after three years away
from the Octagon John Bone Jones is back
for his heavyweight debut Saturday night
March 4th get another title bot against
game and all the action on the fight
card with DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting part of the UFC
new customers you can better fend five
dollars on a pre-fight money line and
get 150 bonus bets if your fighter wins
all draftking customers can join the
excitement with DraftKings same game
parlays combine multiple UFC 285 bets
into one for a shot at an even bigger
payout no forget College basketballs in
full swing pro basketball hockey and
their casino is rocking but start this
week start today
by downloading the Sportsbook app now
use code Joey j-o-e-y new customers can
bet five dollars on any pre-fight money
line and get a hundred and fifty and
free bets of your final wins that's this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook use
code Joey minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details let's get this party started
it's Monday baby
thank you
welcome to Uncle Joey's Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad mother it's
Monday the 27th of February it's a
beautiful week and day to be alive
there's the last week of the month this
dog this month flew again
again it's the 27th I didn't realize
like I realized like Saturday it was the
25th and I'm like
it's February we don't even have six
more days left it's quick Jack so uh
get ready for March you Savages it's
been a great week it's great to be a
week of 60. nothing has changed I still
got pains and aches I still got a fungi
toenail I got a lot of problems but uh
it feels great to be 60. I did it I made
it you know a lot of people rang a lot
of people called I didn't know it was
such a special thing to turn 60. I
thought everybody [__] did it but I
guess not people like congratulations
congratulations okay whatever I'm just
happy to be alive that's basically at
this point in the game I went to the
Philadelphia
Celtic game this week oh my God
I haven't been to a six a game
in Philly since
1983. when I walked in there I told the
girl from Philly was there some girl
came up and welcomed us like how long
have you worked them and she goes oh
about three years I go last time I went
to see a Philly game it was 1983 at the
Spectrum I saw
Philly a lot after that all over the
country I went to see him in Denver and
Phoenix but that was the last time the
new arena is gorgeous
the [__] Cheesesteak my wife got I
was pissed because she we split one and
it was delicious with like white cheese
or something like that it was just great
with my it was on a seeded bread I
didn't eat the fried fries I had the
Coke Zero it was great the energy in
there was [__] outstanding
I thought a couple people from Boston
were gonna get stabbed
listen man
you guys know me I wore a Philly shirt
last night that my neighbor gave me as a
birthday present because she knew I was
going to the game
and my wife got one online and then my
got my daughter went online
if you guys know anything about me I
hate wearing a Jersey to the team I'm
going to if this was anywhere else like
a lakerville and all that I wouldn't
give a Frenchman's [__] but when I go to
Philly I want no misunderstandings that
I'm with them like you know what I'm
saying I don't want and especially with
my family there I don't want no
misunderstandings that I'm in Philly
when I go to Boston if I'm representing
Boston that game I win my little Boston
shirt because I know that place is along
the crazy side if you're a [__]
Raider fan you know there's a lot of
stadiums you can't [__] with people and
I tell you what it's like
it's like when I understand you guys and
I understand what it is to be a fan and
this but I don't I don't understand what
it is to go get kicked in the head by a
[__] beer bottle and guess what I've
seen it in stadiums I saw it once going
to see the Jets against Philly some guy
had a [__] Miami jacket on I thought
they were going to kill this guy with
bottles and pieces of pretzels and [__]
you know look what happened to the
Dodger game California the Land of Love
guy went in there with a San Francisco
he's in a [__] wheelchair today
because they beat him so [__] bad you
know you don't know what they bet you
don't know what they're on you don't
know what they're feeling you don't you
don't know what the [__] going on
so even last time I went to Philly for a
baseball game I saw people yelling at
people you just sit there you don't know
nothing you don't take your camera out
and tape it you mind your business and
you look straight ahead you want to be
Joe Gentile and take your phone out and
you know don't do it in Philly because
I'm telling you you're gonna get clocked
in the [__] head there's no phones
there it is it is just it is just a real
[__] place and I'll tell you man what
the nicest thing I think about Philly I
like is
the brothers in Philly and the sisters
they're just so [__] cool
like Dave in Philadelphia I don't know
if there's race there's racism
everywhere but
it's like the brothers they earned it
like they [__] earned and then nice
to everybody some little [__] kid oh
my God he was the cutest little
black boy you ever saw in your life with
his mom and I was sitting right when you
hit the first stand thank God I didn't
have to walk down those stairs enough
thank God I was right there boom row 17
or something like that
and he came with a soda and before he
went to step the soda just fell out of
his hand
and his mom's like Oh no and the soda's
going down three throws and I looked at
the little boy
he just he was heartbroken
you know and I had like a little my wife
got I think she got like a meal and it
came with a soda but I had Waters
already and I didn't touch my soda I
just gave him the straw with the soda
you know his mom came back
and she's like you didn't need to do
that but it was great that you did you
know most people take those little
gestures for granted she came back and
she was a beautiful sister if my wife
wasn't there I would have tried to talk
to her and [__] you know just no I
wouldn't but it that's the I just like
all that [__] one thing I did notice
that I got to talk to you guys about
I watch games at home football baseball
some nights I watch hockey I watch The
Devils I watch the Rangers
and uh
I tell you what I noticed [__]
athletes today
a trained
just spect I mean I saw some [__] that
wasn't even human
I saw some [__] that wasn't even human
Tatum smart
Joe limbid uh Maxi those guys were doing
things that were
truly [__] amazing just the fact that
Joe and Ben is seven feet six eleven six
ten three hundred Fades a [__]
monster
he moves like
I've never seen it and I saw the mall I
saw Moses I saw Kareem I saw magic
the conditioning that athletes today get
are second to none it's amazing fourth
quarter they're shooting free throws
they're not even breathing heavy
they're not even breathing that but yeah
they have their injuries and [__] some
of the NBA players a little lazier I
want a rest day who the [__] are you to
get arrested nobody rests but they are I
don't know what happened to Fitness you
know if you go to a ma if you go to a
gym today just if you go to any gym and
go you know what I want to get trained
by a trainer I need some help with my
fitness and [__]
either they're going to blast you a
trainer that doesn't really know [__] is
going to blast you the old-fashioned way
which is fine too you know five sets of
six to gain weight uh you know up your
protein you know there's so many [__]
things
I had a friend that never touched a
steroid that was huge
huge muscle wise no stay was [__] 17
he was half a [__] robots but he got
huge doing two work four workouts a week
five sets of six heaviest weight you
could put on it no barbell no dumbbells
it was all barbell like he went old
school a barbell dog he looked great I
saw people in prison that would do
pull-ups and sit-ups and all that [__]
and they looked [__] amazing and
that's old school type training
if you go into a Gym training you know
what I uh
play baseball on a record League
whatever let's say you're 26 28 and you
go I just want to really learn mechanics
and the strength I'm going to do [__]
with you you like why am I doing this
[__]
me walking around with a [__] uh you
know a weight on my back or swinging a
[__] Russian thing or why am I doing
this [__] what are these lunges about
why am I pulling these strings and going
up and down like that and you're like
after about three or four sessions
you're like oh [__] just when I was
about to quit this guy
he's teaching me some different [__] I
work out with a guy once a week
he's busy as [__] I really go with him
from my knee it's instead of going to
physical therapy
I go to this guy from my knee his name
is Tom
I have never met a guy more
knowledgeable about him when it comes to
Fitness I got to be honesty the first
four times I went in there I was like
this ain't gonna last
he was assessing me
seeing where the problems were and he
came back to me with a note one day and
I was like
whoa he's like
when you walk you trip a lot that's
because your muscles aren't strong on
the front of your leg you're not picking
your foot all the way up [__] amazing
[__] he goes this is what I need to I he
goes I know but for you to live pain
free which is what we're getting to and
be healthy this is what the exercises
these days I go in there and do exercise
I don't even know what the [__] he's
doing I just know when I walk out I look
at my whoop and I burn 350 calories and
I did like a 10 [__] and I'm up to a 10
[__] uh whatever with the whoop and
to me that's a great [__] day and not
even knowing what I'm doing he makes you
do these lunges that are completely
different
the first three weeks or four weeks that
I went there halfway and it's only 40
minutes halfway into the to the thing
like he's yeah he's massaging your leg
and he's stretching it and he's pulling
on it and he's [__] but then he makes
you do exercises along with that I
didn't do that in physical therapy and I
went to two different physical therapy
with the doctor [__] recommended and
then I come to realize that after all
that [__] I did with him six seven
months in therapy I didn't even have
[__] leg strength
this guy every time I go in there
the first 20 minutes if I think my
thighs are gonna blow the [__] up and
guess how many weights we use
none
I could swing kettlebells in the
basement after [__] five sets of ten
my thighs are [__] hurting I'm
sweating up a storm
this guy I don't even feel what the [__]
he's doing I'll tell you what I go to
jujitsu
I'm breathing but like I told him once I
had to work on my cardio what are we
doing here he's like Joey
I'm working you in level two cardio and
he started breaking into this [__] about
cardio and I'm like I should have never
opened up this bag of worms then he
started sending me podcasts
because they do all these tremendous
Health podcasts and they started sending
me podcasts of all this [__] these
people talking about level two and level
one uh you know cardio and how you
switch it to three and two and that
number add guys don't quote me on this I
don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about but I'm just letting you know well
guess what I go to Jujitsu now when I
used to go to Jujitsu and I ran up the
stairs I get winded I have to go in the
bathroom and hide for two minutes and
pee from the [__] thing I could run
up that [__] now and nothing
happens you know I could roll for [__] I
can roll two five minutes you know and
listen for you guys are like oh Joey
what the guys that's all I got I'm an
old man I don't I do four or five five
minute rolls you ain't seen me [__]
10 days you know I like the what Rogan
Tyson told Rogan Rogan goes I like that
tape you made a couple years ago if you
hit in the midst with the guy from Kings
and he goes bro that workout it took me
a week to get out of bed that's what
happens that's what happens when you're
[__] old those muscles you haven't
used them in a while so it's pretty
interesting what they're doing the
explosiveness
the conditioning you know explosiveness
comes from strength these guys aren't
walking around looking like Arnold
Schwarzenegger they're [__] famous
[__] they're skinny they're [__]
explosive they when they're around the
rim it's like it's a shame
it's when I used to go to games in the
80s and 90s you know the rim was
something yeah I got to jump up there
now these guys just jump an inch and
they're by the [__] rimmer at least
it seemed like an inch and they're up
there up in the [__] day like what I
saw Jason Tatum do some drives
that the power the explosiveness was
just
[__] outrageous so I don't know if
you're training this way if you're not I
know for sure I ain't training that way
I do three of those explosive moves
you're done you won't see me for a
[__] weekend the mat you got to move
quick and stuff sometimes but I do two
or three of those and Uncle Joe is no
bueno for a [__] uh
for [__] a few days or so I want to
talk to you guys about something that I
noticed last week that I need to explain
to you guys
and I want to talk to you guys about the
truth uh
for me during the pandemic all these you
know if you if you're on Instagram and
you say anything like hey like even when
I was making videos on Instagram the
city I would say look at nobody's got a
mask on tonight
and when I looked at the video it said
misinformation
covered misinformation you know and
that's all you hear about and you don't
even know whether you're coming or going
half the [__] time
when I wake up in the morning I don't
you know sometimes I'll play music I
play music in the car but when I wake up
in the morning I don't want no drama so
I just put YouTube on you know I just
put YouTube on there's an album I want
to listen to YouTube's got everything
okay and it's quick I don't have to come
in here and clean the needle and
look for the [__] album you know I
ain't got that type of patience I had to
eat the [__] more than seven in the
morning so I just go to YouTube but it's
interesting when I click onto the
YouTube page every morning it's a
[__] Adventure
it's just an adventure and it's it's
some people talking about educational
stuff you know Rhonda Patrick the other
guy talking about testosterone uh you
know just a bunch of good stuff because
I don't tag on to a bunch of [__] but
then as I scroll down you know looking
for music or something like that I'll
see like
just videos of people talking about
Comics you know and I and I'll just read
the [__] fine print like and I'll go
these guys have no idea
what they're talking about
and it's sad because then other people
read these things and they think they
got to know it all on these Comics
whoever they may be or actors or
whatever and you know when you talk
about a generic actor I don't know much
about them when you say something about
John Bernthal and I'm watching it I'm
like these people have no idea what
they're talking about that they really
don't
yeah everybody's [__] PMZ breaking
late news they taste stuff and they
twist it in these videos and you sit
there and go like I said I would watch
those videos till about nine months ago
and then when I said you know what when
I watch those videos they really give me
anxiety
they really do whatever the [__] they
are whether they're talking about the
guy from the radio or what I'm like the
same for me
and I found one about a month ago about
two [__] white dudes I never even
seen before
talking about why
the church broke up
that dog there's millions of videos out
there
a handful of ones that are like bigger
on YouTube this is like two guys just
talking they had a podcast I don't know
what the name of the podcast was
and they were talking about
pressure and we had to get out of town
and it was like did this warrants out
and I'm like and it was an old video it
had to be about
two years after we moved
and Lisa yeah is about to do an
interview and and just I was looking at
this and I'm like what the [__] and the
reasons why and none of them after like
four minutes I turned the video I go
none of these things were correct
they were just talking and I don't even
know who mentioned these things because
I never even heard this [__] before that
they were talking about
and then last week it was my birthday
weekend and Lee came Mike Cahill and I
go Lee let's do a podcast and I did a
podcast with Lee the way I did a million
other podcasts with Lee
and it wasn't until about two days later
that you guys started sending me
pictures and little messes I got a lot
of messages from that podcast last week
weird ones but all good on the positive
side you know we're happy you and Lima
Baba and again that's what I'd
understand like what are you happy that
me me and Lee have always been cool
after we ended the podcast there was a
couple weeks of you know bad feelings
like why how but he wasn't the right
mental state and guess what neither was
[__] I neither was I but one guy sent
a picture
to my Facebook and it was brilliant he
took a shot of me and Lee last Saturday
last Monday and he took a shot of me and
Lee like
January of 2020. I don't know who we had
on the podcast
guys I looked at that picture and I was
like whoa
well
to see it
and to think it and to read it
was to see it [__] shocked me
like I had a neck
I didn't have swelling around my face
Lee lost he lost a head
his head with the picture I saw January
and I have a picture that Lee looks just
got off I took that picture because I
was like
this is the last time when I see this
kid the next time I see these kids in a
hospital room or something
I know I stared at that picture and I
sent them the picture about a year after
we moved and he was in shock he was he
looked like a ball of salt
it's like salt had just creeped into his
body and let me tell you what happened
guys
we started the podcast in to that let's
get back to it I was doing a podcast
with Felicia
started bringing up some rough topics
you know
and Felicia's a [__] sweetheart
that's another person I adore she hit me
up this week she met the guy
that was the cinematographer on a movie
her and I really enjoyed Soul power it
was a movie about a festival in Africa
around Muhammad Ali and I think George
Foreman or Joe Frazier I don't know
and you know we're just tight man she
comes to visit me she's come I flew back
here with her when we moved she flew
with us a lot of people don't know that
yeah she came back here with us
and we're tight man so to see like that
Lee and I weren't getting along
those are all lies and what happened was
this man we were Lee and I started that
podcast in a [__] bedroom
and then my wife got knocked up so we
must have started that podcast in 2012.
then my wife got knocked up and then we
went to his apartment
and guys it was
just a [__] podcast it was just two
guys talking [__] we had a guy call in
from time to time in the mornings at six
in the morning we had guests calling in
a [__] nightmare we didn't have no
idea what we're doing and then
we [__] uh lee got a girlfriend she
was moving in so we got a studio and
that studio was a [__] disaster the
lady threw us out she kept banging on
the door
but guys this [__] was all [__] fun
you know it was just it was a podcast
that was about fun
we did the acid we did you know it was
just fun it hadn't been done before on a
podcast so we took you guys out of you
know now they do everything on podcasts
but it was fun
and then
we moved into the office the office that
we ended the podcast with
and whatever we were doing at the other
office on Lankershim
and the other office I mean it all came
to a boil that
but something happened that crossed
paths I was having a great time guys I'm
selling out shows
I'm starting to make money after 20
years in the [__] business
and I'm very excitable my wife had a
child
I got invited to do uh Oddball Fest
which for years they wouldn't even talk
to me that was a
great feather in my cap I got to
apologize to Wendy from Denver we we
came to an agreement of what had
happened with me that is saying I
smacked the girl's ass you know whatever
and everything was fine you know
everything was going great
but like everything else in life you
want more and I did want a Netflix
special
I really did guys
I thought that if I got a special I
thought I was ready I was never ever
good at specials before
I had shot one for a company I had a
couple CDs
but Netflix was big the problem was my
agent
couldn't sell it
so he came to me one then he goes I got
the way to get you on Netflix
we're going to get you a manager
he really likes you he's called about
you a few times
and he was a great manager with a great
management team behind him at this time
I had
the number one manager and the top
agency in my corner like again 10 years
ago 20 years ago these [__]
wouldn't even have wanted me in the room
and now I got the best two agents in the
world
or management team and whatever
so I'm very excited I'm thinking that
now is my chance
to do whatever the [__] I want so again
I sold the TV show to Fox on an idea I
had that was great you know when I first
got to La when you got a developmental
deal you had an idea they were giving
you Millions a half a millions or six
figures I got neither of that [__] I got
like 22 [__] Grand I'm telling you
guys the truth here's a [__] TV show
and I get 22 Grand I know a guy that got
a million dollars and never even wrote a
pilot
I wrote a pilot I got 22 Grand
afterwards
again it's not about the money it's
about the opportunity and I'm telling
you these facts just to be honest as
honest I can with you
that I want to show yeah I wanted to do
the show
it would have been something different
it would have been
it would have been great you know but I
knew come on guys I'm never gonna make
this work I'm gonna say something
I can't be in a corporate setting so it
all went down the drain and I was okay
with that
I was having a great time being a comic
I really was it was exciting to travel
but I was wearing myself down man it was
a lot and I didn't know it at all two
podcasts a week doing two other people's
podcast a week you know four planes a
[__] week you know wanted to get to
the first place then you do the [__]
theater then you gotta get another
flight and go to another [__] town on
Saturday morning and then Sunday you're
right back at it again again I'm not
whining this is part of the thing but
for 20 years for the last 50 years
nobody had a podcast
so people were just doing comedy and
every once in a while you booked a movie
and then you canceled comedy and shot
the movie whatever
I was growing I was burning the candle
on both sides plus guys we're [__]
smoking
major pounds of weed we're going through
a [__] quarter a day of high-end 30
28 27 percent weed seven days a [__]
week you know anywhere you go there's
weed anywhere any Comedy Club you go to
this weed not to mention we're eating
[__] 2 000 milligrams of THC a night
not to mention the [__] five six
hundred I'm doing in the daytime on my
own popping every time I go buy a
[__] desk now on paper that sounds
like a lot of fun but let me tell you
something I don't know if you guys ever
saw
The Joe Rogan podcast when he had Tom
seguran and Tom was talking about the
trip I took with him but I took him on
the plane and I made him eat a gummy and
he had anxiety and then when when the
plane landed and Joe Rogan said
something very intelligent he goes
listen man some people would look at
that
say that might be a problem now
I'll never forget those words
and in my world what I was doing was
there was no problem
I was just living my [__] life that's
how I do it you know there's no [__]
part-timing in my life or you're gonna
do it listen when I what I got sick of
and I wanted to prove something against
was that I was dealing with all these
[__] L.A Comics like all of a sudden
all of a sudden they were big Stoners
and they weren't
they [__] weren't at all they just
jumped on a bandwagon to get you people
to buy into it and you people bought
into it and I was [__] disgusted I'm
like dog I've been smoking since the
[__] womb and you guys are [__]
selling huh well look at me dude get the
[__] out of here so I wanted to bust
that [__] open and I did these
[__] were all fakes and you saw
it we were blowing them out of the water
by Miles these [__] guys I was
getting challenged from all over the
world through bong hits for ten thousand
guys come on what what have we done what
do I got a [__] Yama go with a
propeller on my [__] head I'm not
doing that [__] you [__] crazy so
then something happened
I was eating Cuban food my wife when
they had old cochinito in Silver Lake
and out of nowhere my phone rings
and it's the manager
and as a matter of fact it was my age
and he goes hey man the manager is going
to call you in a few minutes
he's got something for you he got a
Netflix offer for you
and deep down inside I was [__] happy
and also he called me and goes man
congratulations I got you this [__]
show it's a half hour
I'm like I just finished my meal I thank
them I said we'll talk on Monday it was
like a Friday night or a Saturday night
I [__] uh ate my meal and that Monday
I called him and I was like
a half hour
what the [__] he's like listen this is
the start do the half hour you're gonna
get great numbers then they'll come back
at you for an hour blah blah blah and
I'm like okay that sounds great
I'm working it backwards but you know
what I'm that type of comic I'm not in
the circle of the comics or comics
yeah I wasn't in that Circle you know
what I'm saying so I get it there's
Comics that just took it home and
Netflix calls them they don't even go
out every night to do comedy yeah and
Netflix calls them and again I'm not
talking out of jealousy here or nothing
I'm talking to you about facts so you
know where the [__] I'm coming from hey
we're taking a minute from the podcast
so I could talk to you about better help
these past couple years have been
especially taxing on all our mental
health you could see it but what people
are saying you see this guy Santos you
know it's not been good lately I felt
the same way about myself and I figured
I'd try better help better help is
online therapy that can get you back to
the best version of yourself simply fill
out the questionnaire get Max with a
licensed therapist and let me tell you
something you'll be matched within 48
hours you'll be talking to a therapist
online on video however you want listen
if you don't like your therapist you can
switch counselors at any time easily for
no additional cost it's convenient
affordable and entirely online and Dana
helped me a ton so if you're looking for
a little help if you're looking to get
sent it right now visit betterhelp.com
Diaz again that's betterhelp.com Diaz
today I'm going to get you 10 off your
first month when you put in Diaz how's
that that's betterhelp.com
Diaz take care of yourselves guys it's
rough out there for a Pimp
so I get this Netflix special
and while I'm preparing for the Netflix
special
did drive me crazy the agent and the
manager
are driving me crazy I'm getting 10
calls a day of stupidity
just stupidity
and the whole time I'm like I can't
believe I signed with this guy I'm
paying him 15 [__] percent
and he didn't get me what I wanted and
on top of that besides the script
everything he's presenting to me
is not what I want to do
you know he would be at all you know
when you get a special Netflix will come
see you every once in a while and
they'll let you know we're coming to see
you tonight to see your material well
they came to see me a total of four
times in five [__] months or
something three months I don't know what
the preparation was
never we love it thank you that was
great
you know and I was just trying different
things out I was trying to push the
envelope in front of them to save for
them to say listen you can't use that
reword then that's fine
these [__] I get to that night
of the shooting Vegas Theo's there a
bunch of guys are there we're having a
great time and all of a sudden I got a
knock on my trail at six o'clock that
Netflix wants to see me to go over my
material
and right then and there they just
[__] dump on me what they didn't want
look I gotta share with her now
you're gonna hit me with this [__] now
I have a notebook but it doesn't have my
whole repertoire it has what I'm working
on now it doesn't happen you know
sometimes when it's late you can move
[__]
and I went to my manager and I went to
the age and like what the [__] is going
on and these guys were like
it is what it is they they made Tom do
it no you don't understand that that
right before and on top of that not
never you guys gotta have my [__]
back
and you know what man I'm I'm a big
enough dude from the training I did when
I used to be really upset I used to drop
my daughter off and then I'm going to
force myself to do comedy that training
came back
because as much as I didn't want to do
that [__] half hour special I was
like you know what Joey Clee had going
there and Tackle this [__] okay
I walk in
now you know Vegas has 80 [__]
facilities stages that are gorgeous all
sizes these [__] Knuckleheads pick a
pool hall okay a [__] pool hall
come on you ever do stand up at a pool
hall
you hear balls hitting even if they shut
it off I'm lying to you guys but it's a
big room no we used to do comedy
Hollywood Billy it's me Rogue and Josh
Wolf for years they pay you 50 bucks
you're in there cracking jokes and
people are yelling at the eight ball you
know you're like okay I gotta crack a
joke over this [__]
so
you know I'm in there I'm [__]
watching uh mommy you know Tom seguru's
wife
Tina Christina she's on stage 10 minutes
and also the Vault falls down like you
came out of a vault when they announced
your name there was like some little
[__] Puerto Rican dude with a string
and they opened the Vault and fire would
come on you would come up when they
opened the Vault the whole Vault fell
down they had to stop the show you know
and I'm like
what I just [__] say why are we doing
comedy in a [__] pool when and again
guys this is my fault
because I was caught up so much
by the thought of shooting a special
that I didn't take a look at the little
details that was my bad but my manager
and agent
did nothing
no warning no protection and let's be
honest with you I want updated a bag of
dick
to what I wanted to do to what I was
used to doing
and I went up to the second show and I
did a little better but it wasn't much
and that's when I went to my room that
night I had a good time I was happy my
friends went had a great time with Lee
everybody was there
but I was angry that night I was like
this ain't
to say what I signed up for you know I
remember being behind The Comedy Store
the stairs
and we would sit there when we had
nothing
or we would just become regulars me Ari
you know Stephen is easy Bobby Lee and
we talk about our dreams and how we
couldn't wait to be with a big agency
and a great manager and this [__] that
we're going through isn't happening
anymore well guess what it happens now
that you have a management agent and all
the peace you got to work double to
[__] get that [__]
and at the same time this manager and
this agent aren't listening to me
you know I never forget I did a show and
I go listen I'm taking some time off
you know I'm doing this I'm going to do
that and they're like yeah yeah yeah and
with the same breath in mind you looked
at me because you know what I think we
should do
we should get a camera for the road and
put it in front of your face with a
screen so people could see your face I'm
like that's not stand up that's an arena
that's not what I want to do and for the
next couple weeks everything they were
thrown at me was [__] I was uninterested
in doing I did not want to [__] do
half this [__] as a matter of fact these
people will bother me and as a matter of
fact it was climbing on into my life but
something else had happened
around that time I went to the store one
night like I did for [__] 30 years
and they come back then they go Joey
you're up next
and
I was smoking a joint whatever the [__]
I was doing I go let's go do it like
I've done a thousand times
and I run through the hallway I say
hello to people you know who's in the
hallway Aaron Griffin I walk up to the
top of the stairs in the original room I
looking And that really great girls up
there the writer I forget what her name
is she just moved back to L.A she was
close with Stanhope living down there
and dog I got a batch of anxiety that I
couldn't see
guys I got anxiety that I couldn't
[__] see
my hearing was going in and out
I was starting to fly I couldn't breathe
this is something I've been doing all my
life and here I am am I having a heart
attack
I'll never forget that I looked out the
window I Comedy Store behind the stage
there's a window to the right hand side
of the comics they had coveted it that
made me panic more so I went to walk
down the stairs now I'm really out of
oxygen
I just wanted to see the outside of the
street this is all happening at the
comedy store with with the light on what
that means is I'm next and she's gonna
end at any [__] minute now
so I run up the stairs looking for
anybody for help and I see Paulie Shaw
who I [__] love and I go up to him I
go Paulie
come here I can't breathe like a Paulie
come here I gotta talk to you about
something he's like what's up I gotta
listen dog
I uh can't get on stage I got a horrible
[__]
I can't breathe
because you don't look good buddy you
want some water I go no I got some right
here but I don't think I should go up on
stage and he looks at me goes I already
went up
can't go up against Paulie who gave us a
[__]
just go up there and tell him Joe he's
gonna be give me two minutes to get mad
because nah bro you're on it yourself
and I'm like God damn it Paulie
[__] with that Joey he is
guys I went up to the stage and I never
blew it up to what it was
I remember talking to Paulie
and next thing I remember is
being on the stage and within two
minutes the light coming on
that's all I remember
and people were [__] howling and I
don't know what I said I don't know what
I had done now this is a joke amongst us
but it's not guys
I walked off that stage I had a pee
right away I was sweating I had tingles
in my body I'm like I'm gonna [__]
die
and I went to the car I peed I went to
the car and I just sat there for like 15
minutes I got my bearings to me and I
went home
in 2007 I got off the blow
and I was fine at first you know you're
I was I was off the blow I was off
alcohol I was off without anything else
I was doing that was crazy but now I go
to the doctor and then I go doc
I don't know from time to time I have a
hard time breathing because listen this
is anxiety
let me give you these pills he gave me
those football Xanaxes so
I don't know I would take them one or
two when I felt it and then leave them
at home I would be out at night and I
would get anxiety but it never bothered
me again after that bout at the store
I'll never forget I had Rogan that week
and I had to go on Rogan and tell him
the story and as we were leaving he's
like bro that sounds crazy
I didn't explain I wasn't totally honest
with everybody about it but I blacked
out guys
and after that my anxiety level started
going up after that Netflix thing I
don't know what happened to me something
wasn't right
and guess what guys I I got up all the
way to I was 340 pounds 336.
I was smoking God knows how much I was
eating God knows how much my diet was
okay but my sleeping wasn't good and
when you're not sleeping good
you're not thinking clearly you know the
sleep apnea wasn't affecting me but uh
to [__] sleep in five hours having to
fly having to sleep two hours all that
[__] wears on your system I didn't
[__] know it who knows it who [__]
knows it we're [__] gangsters you
know what I'm saying we don't have time
to [__] bleed
and guys somewhere around that time I'm
like I gotta start eating these [__]
Xanaxes so here I mean the Xanaxes and
at the time I was eating maybe two of
that I was eating one in the morning and
one at night to sleep and they were fine
and I'm [__] I'm not drinking on them
thank God and I'm smoking weed like a
[__] I'm thinking Edibles like
a [__] I'm eating ass like a
[__] you know I asked Lydia that
go leave remember those bottles of
liquid we were drinking they were 200
milligrams
we would drink one of those just to when
I saw them they were like a pirate teeth
like hey what's going on take a tube and
leave it go not again and he'd drink it
you know
and
between the Xanax the Edibles right then
and there 2017 was where I started a
drop
I felt the drop
in
my connection with Lee was dropping I
believe was starting comedy and I was
very happy for him but I didn't want him
to become a Brendan job like for people
to go after Brent like I didn't want
people to go out to Lee how they went
after Brendan I appreciate what Brendan
did but at the end of the day a lot of
you people are right he was given too
much too fast I love Brendan I'm not
saying nothing bad about him
what happened was that that you don't
react well to that when you're a young
comic you don't guys all that up front
of the third the second year is not
healthy for anybody
and I looked actively you know and I I
kept them at home he went on the road me
some weeks but for the most part he
would stay home and do stand up and that
was based around our relationship but
our relationship was starting to wear
down because we were one the [__] down
we were worn down and it didn't dawn on
me how worn down we were
until like November 2019.
we would do the podcast and usually we
were talking every day three or four
times a day we would do that podcast on
Wednesday we wouldn't talk to you until
Sunday
and I knew right then it wasn't
we were going both directions he dumped
Paul after that you know he started a
new life but our [__]
edible use and listen guys I'm the first
one to tell you that you could smoke
dope all day and and
two Edibles all day and it won't affect
you I used to be able to say that now I
can't look in the eye and say that
because it all has an effect for you and
all that all that [__] together mixed
together the way it was guys I was
drinking eight to ten expressos a day
eight to ten guys not to what does a fat
[__] need 10 coffees for a day
and I mean I couldn't live without those
coffees at all at all I would have to
drink one or two one at five before I
took out of martial arts I would do four
or three cup espresso at eight o'clock
not [__] Starbucks ass water Cuban
espresso with [__] 10 scoops of sugar
[__] deal and on top of that I'm
eating a [__] Xanax to get out of the
house
on top of that I'm on [__] uh
a medication that I threw the [__] out
when I moved here and it [__] with me
for a while but I fought a lot it was
the vertigo medication
that [__] was [__] me up as stupid as
it sounds because it was giving me pukes
I would puke once a week to guys that
was a [__] mess you know not rehab
mess or anything like that but I was
just a mess and
I was getting unhappier and unhappier
and every day I would ask myself
how can you work hard for 20 [__]
years
to where you you are
get to the best part of your career and
you're just not [__] happy
I want it off the road not because I
didn't like comedy no more because I was
burnt I was burning the candle with the
podcast room listen I lived and died in
that podcast room
lived and died in that podcast room when
I would go to that podcast I leave my
soul there all the time when they're
telling stories telling something I had
never told before I would leave my soul
on that [__] podcast but when I knew
it was definitely [__] time to
abandon ship was the daily and I did
ketamine on a Sunday [__] afternoon
it was fun you know and then we did it
did a podcast
and then the guy left like a gram of it
and we did it in two lines and I was
[__] gone I'm gonna forget doing a
line getting in the car and by the time
I got to the light I didn't know where
the [__] I was
I had to make a left turn and I couldn't
feel my legs and then I got to my house
and when I pulled my leg out of the car
in the driveway no bueno guys
I had to pull my leg back and slam the
door and sit in there for like 45
minutes I was [__] up and then I went
in the house and guess what out of all
the nights my door my wife to stay up
she's [__] up watching
true laws that show with the [__]
dude from the green book and the other
dude at the time and I'm in the office
tripping out
I'm like listen if I don't go out there
and see my wife she's gonna come in here
and check on me
I might as well go out there and see my
wife and I went out there and I sat on
the couch and within minutes I started
sweating profusely I had to take my
[__] shirt off
but she's like why are you sitting like
that I'm like it's hot in here finally
the guy we were watching the guy from
the green book his head started doing
proof on the screen and I sat down after
two minutes I go take this off and she's
like what the [__] is going on with you
I go I'll tell you in the morning I
didn't come clean with her in the
morning that the academy she didn't know
how to [__] react to it
but I remember her looking at me going
Joey this can't continue you guys are
going crazy I mean we would go I would
leave to do a podcast at seven o'clock
at night and I'd walk in the door at 1
30 in the morning
you know how many times we got to the
podcast at seven with a guest and would
talk [__] for an hour and a half maybe
two hours before the podcast and then
kick ourselves in the ass we didn't turn
this on and by that time we're [__]
blasted on THC they're drinking they're
doing whatever the [__] but the good
thing was there was no alcohol a lot of
the nights most of the night so there's
no booze I think Ron White one night we
drank with it was never any cocaine
except for two people who did Coke in
there and it had nothing to do with us
you know we weren't doing anything like
that we didn't lose control like that we
just lost control of themselves and I
caught myself on those podcasts
just talking nonsense
it was just nonsense it wasn't what I
wanted to do anymore
I knew I wasn't [__] healthy I didn't
know how unhealthy I was but I knew for
a fact my little buddy Lee was really
unhealthy and very unhappy you don't
shove your food in your face like that
when you're happy he was unhappy I was
unhappy and it wasn't until
the pandemic that we were in there one
day he's coughing
and I go when is this going to end we're
not we're not going to get no better
we're not going to come out of this
pandemic any better than I remember
saying in the beginning
a lot of people are going to change
during this pandemic
and man
my [__] words to God's ears because
I'm gonna forget I'm like we can't
continue to do this anymore either that
I gotta add a new person in here I
didn't want to get rid of Lee even
though listen this is the beauty about
it once I'm just getting 100 emails a
week to get rid of Lee
and I refused I [__] refused I think
I was getting frustrated and there was
moments but I couldn't do it but when I
saw the twitch that night when he fell
asleep on the twitch that was the night
I said we need to do something
either I send him a way to get help
we take a break from the podcast and I
said none of that's gonna work
and I think a few days landed my wife
said to me listen
we got a house in Jersey if we want it
and just to let you know there's not
going to be any school
in California until June
and I called Jimmy Florentine and
everything was done and we decided to
break that thing up and you know the
rumors were flying oh my god when I saw
that I don't want to repeat them because
they're the dumbest things in the world
where people took from that I feel so
bad for them you know for even coming to
those conclusions because nobody had
said those things I still remember when
we had the YouTube pays that the guy was
putting my Clips on it and I said he
couldn't use it anymore and he's like I
have hidden footage of you guys doing
cocaine and having orgy and come on guys
who's gonna have an orange man fuckingly
get your [__] life together guys
it has a lot of conspiracy about
podcasts and [__] oh yeah and it's like
just nothing happened
we just looked at each other one day and
said we can't keep going at this [__]
rate we just can't keep doing it no more
and I was [__] miserable my anxiety
was to an all-time level
those [__] Xanaxes I went from eating
two a day to eat in 10 a [__] day two
at a [__] chunk because my heart
wouldn't stop [__] beating you know
what it was
the Xanax was making me do that because
Xanax is only supposed to be used for
two weeks to cure anxiety until you get
to the medication whether they give you
Zoloft Protestant this that dude that
bust Barton whatever the [__] they
decide to give you if you read anything
about Xanax it'll tell you it's just a
temporary [__] thing three four days
and you got to get off that [__] between
that my unhappiness
and this is what was sad about that then
how can you be [__] unhappy when you
have you're selling out theaters Joey
but something occurred and all that The
Sopranos
and listen there's always a silver
lining while I was shooting a movie I
thought it would have been I thought it
would be a good movie
there was a couple things that I
questioned but I think they would have
cleaned them up
but the thing I got the most out of that
movie I enjoyed working for David Chase
it was great but I came home with no Lee
three weeks no wife no kid and I told my
agents after the third day because they
wouldn't stop with the oh I just spoke
to Cleveland when are you going to make
that data I don't give a [__] I don't
really give a [__] I'm on a second movie
I'm having a good time as a matter of
fact don't call till I'm back in
California
I'm never addicted people but I had to
make that rule because they didn't get
it I'd be in the middle I was excited
just to be on a [__] set they didn't
want to hear
you know why they didn't want to hear it
because the movie only pays you 600 a
day that's 60 commission time
that's why they rather have you getting
beat up on the [__] road so that
commissions are a lot higher they'll
tell you how happy you are that you got
the oh we're so happy and proud of you
that you got the movie they [__]
hating life because you're not making
them any [__] money so they don't
want you there and the whole time
they're calling you trying to throw you
off your game hey what do you think
about this date for Missouri what do you
think about this day for New Year's Eve
listen do me a favor don't call me no
more and those three weeks is when I was
like holy [__]
holy [__] this is [__] tremendous
I'm out of Los Angeles which I
definitely needed to break out of
I'm here without Lee
which at that time kind of felt good
I needed a break from everybody but when
I came back I realized how much I loved
Lee and how I won and even until today
man
what I found out since I moved here is
I love that little guy I you know he
helped me get my word out to the [__]
world
he helped me put a vision together I
didn't know I even had in my [__]
head and at the end of the day Mike will
tell you anybody will tell you that's
been around him he's a very very sweet
kid
all that talk and violence and drug use
and eating ass that must have
traumatized that [__] kid he's a
sweet sweet kid
and yes when I got on that plane when he
left I listen I was never going to leave
him there
was listen there was no way I was going
to leave him there I would have waited
till he was ready to leave
and both him and Steve Simone who I
loved daily
I was like dog when I go I'm taking you
with me even if you're moving with me I
do not want you staying out here
and that was it and once I got here
it was weird Lee was in Milwaukee and we
were talking but it's like we were still
mad at each other about breaking up the
podcast because when I went to him I
didn't go to him in bad terms or
anything I just want them to leave this
ain't working
I don't want you to move to this
neighborhood with me this is all
families
you know you're just going to be down
here alone again
I don't want you alone I know what it is
to be alone I was alone in L.A for 23
[__] years enough of this [__] go
home get grounded go to your mother's
get that feeling again go in that
[__] bedroom as a kid going to your
garage and he did and he [__] one day
he got he told me I'm losing his [__]
weight
I'm walking when he was in Milwaukee one
night he called me
and he said he got so high he was eating
kitkats and he fell asleep on the
kitkats and when he woke up they were
all melted
this should not be happening to a 30
year old guy at the time and that's when
we had to talk about Lee you got to take
care of yourself and he went for a walk
and [__] and started a patreon and
everything was great I got to tell you
something our relationship today
is better than ever and I think he came
down here at one time
at this time or the time before one of
the times we did a podcast with him
and I gotta be honest to you somewhere
somewhere in my mind I was like well
maybe I'll ask Lee to do the podcast
again
and I remember us sitting here that
podcast he was over here and I was over
here I think Steve Simone was here one
of those
and I'll never forget that I said it
would never work again
I don't want to do the podcast for him
I'd rather have him as my friend and as
my confidant
for me to even Mike said to me when
let's do this I could be here in 15
minutes Mike doesn't know we can't go
back there like I
can you imagine us eating mushrooms now
and [__] 500 milligrams of Edibles
you'll never get home Mike
your wife will be calling me gonna talk
come on man he [__] shows up he's
bleeding from his eyeballs you know but
I do it I know you do it I would do it
[__] too I was doing it when you guys
were doing it we're doing it yeah
thing was that it was a time
there was a time for it we were both
wounded [__] deer and we made it work
because we needed each other on that
podcast now we're not wounded there
anymore I know exactly what I want to do
and what I don't want to do and I'll
tell you what guys you've looked at me
the last month tomorrow's a month since
I've been on stage
I look better I feel better and I'm
gonna tell you what the problem was I
don't like [__] hanging over my head no
more I don't like it I don't like living
here on February 27th and going [__] I
March 4th I got to drive to the city
that [__] bothers me anymore I'd rather
do it as a hobby I'd rather show up
and have a good time that's a conclusion
I've come up to I don't know what I'm
going to do in my future but I don't
want to take my life to where it was
it's completely different now and it
can't even go there if even if I wanted
to I don't have the time and the energy
to put into that [__]
I'm having a great time as a dad I'm
having a great time with Mike look I
told Michael Mike we ain't doing
Wednesdays no more not happy it makes me
too stressed out boom we do one day a
week I get my [__] out you guys get
motivated I get motivated we're all
[__] happy for me to sit here and
talk for three hours those days are over
I ain't got three hours in me you don't
want to hear me for three hours you know
what I'm saying I'm getting emails now
Joe you're not funny no more uh I tried
to tell you you wouldn't [__] listen
yeah some guy hit me up Monday morning
you're not funny now more I don't like
you on the pot okay I told you guys I'm
not the same [__] person what do you
want me to whip [__] balloons out of
my ass and be a [__] magic trick if I
can I can't [__] do it
and that's it and that's that for a
beautiful [__] Monday morning I love
exactly where I'm [__] going right
now and it's a positive directions and
just to drop something on you
[__] real quick just to let you
know I'm a man of [__] many
opportunities take a look at this
[__] reefer right here
this is as beautiful as this gets this
is made by laughing gas but it's not one
of my brands at all
this brand is called
guava Kush
it's not one of my weeds I'm telling you
right now
if you're in any if you're close to
laughing gas in Studio City
if anytime you go into a wheat store
they have this guava runs it's called
jump on it buy it all out this is some
of the best reefer i've smoked let me
tell you I've been smoking this weed for
a week I did two bong hits Saturday
night after the Philly game I passed out
in my [__] chair this weed is still
getting me sunk
smells like [__] it smells like a Greek
Shake did it aerobics for an hour and
didn't [__] Zoom her little monkey
that's what it smells like it smells
tremendous I love it I gave a little bit
to Mike there he's ready for the week
he's tip top two I got my little bud
left I got a couple buds of this left
and I got another surprise for you
[__]
boom
it's here it's in hand
and it's ready for you [__] to
order tremendous the life of a comedy
[__] Savage guess what I got nice
pictures in here for you dummies in here
you guys like pictures
yeah but they're not like great pictures
this is pictures you probably saw before
but I got the pictures of families that
took me in and that meant more to me to
having that than anything I don't know
if these are pre-prints or whatever now
I can't find the pictures
oh here we are
I got the runnies I got [__] Mr T the
Benders I got [__] Burt Reynolds in
this [__] I got my boys I got my
two brothers that died early on ah
you'll see the book when you [__] get
it yourself it's a great book it's a
great [__] read uh I won it on
Saturday and started doing the audio
book that was a lot of fun I started
doing the audio book March 7th but it's
here [__] and thanks for you
guys and thanks for all of you guys that
the years on the church for letting me
[__] tell some of these stories uh to
you and really polish them up there's
other [__] I found in the air that I was
like wow I can't believe I gave that
info but it's good info for you guys to
know so you know how to [__] this
whole thing came apart they're here
amazon.com you could pre-order right now
you'll get it may [__] second
you bad [__] so I thank you very
much for having my back on this
it was great for me to do was one of the
things I really wanted to do and that's
where I'm at you bad [__] so
thank you thank you for another uh great
weekend thank you for letting me be me
and thank you for understanding where
the [__] we came from why that podcast
and what I want you to learn from that
is guys
a lot of people called me names A lot of
people sent me hate mail when I canceled
it we weren't going nowhere with that
podcast we had accomplished everything
that we could have it was time to move
on to the next chapter of Our Lives I
know it's very hard for people to do
that sometimes
but sometimes you have to learn from
that shut it down rebuild see where
you're going and start all over again
and that's what we did listen The Joint
ain't the church by no means but I
didn't want to do the church again
I didn't want to do the church again I
didn't want to come and do bong hits you
guys already knew all this [__] I wanted
to give you something different whether
I'm giving you that or not whatever I'm
trying my [__] hardest you bad
[__] so thank you and uh have a
great week and here's the [__] word
from our sponsors all right you Savages
thank you thank you for letting me
explain myself to what happened
and thank you for being here on a
beautiful Monday the 27th of February
don't forget
listen this Saturday after three years
John Bone Jones is making a comeback to
heavyweight and he's coming with a
Vengeance for UFC 285 he's fighting
serial game and all the other action on
the fight card
start with DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting part of the UFC
new customers spent five dollars on any
pre-fight money line and I'm Gonna Get
You 150 in free bets when your fighter
wins it's that easy all DraftKings
customers can join the excitement with
DraftKings same game polish oh you got
everything you got rounds decisions
whether they get them in a submission
come on now but it starts with you
download the app use code Joey new
customers can bet just five dollars on a
pre-fight money line and get 150 and
bonus bets of your final wins that's
this Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook
with code Joey j-o-e-y minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details the joint is also
brought to you by come on freeze pipe
Jack stop burning your lungs when you
smoke get freeze pipe for a nice cold
hit every time the pipe comes with a
detachable chamber that you pop in the
freezer for an hour before you want to
see the devil what
or the pipe forget about it it's
non-toxic freezes faster than water and
it stays Frozen for longer freeze pipe
cools down the Smoke by hundreds of
degrees for more enjoyable inhale
whether you hit the pipe bubble or bong
dab we got it all go to freeze pipe
right now pressing code Diaz listen
these pipes are made Solid and they hit
you like a [__] mule get your bong
pipe or bubbler today that's thefreeze
pipe.com pressing code Diaz d-i-a-c
the ISD what the [__] see if you could
smoke it freeze pipe Mason go to show
notes for details I want to thank better
help I want to thank the DraftKings I
want to thank free Spike for having my
backing for sponsoring the show I love
you guys and I'll see you next Monday
tip top magooie Louie
[Music]
foreign